keyyo and cavallero délégué national crs
du syndicat alliance bonjour à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france ce rapport de jacques toubon
souhaite réformer le maintien de l'ordre
à la française est ce que c'est un
camouflet pour les autorités et que
pensez vous également de ce rapport
bonjour non ce n'est pas un camouflet
moi ce que je pense de ce rapport c'est
s'est fait par une personne qui est dans
un bureau qu'il connaît pas du tout le
terrain une femme plus haut dans le
climat ambiant c'est à dire on a révisé
une fois les forces de l'ordre tentaient
de leur enlever les moyens dont il
dispose voilà notamment chez les jeunes
mais sur les caisses et des
attroupements
c'était pas des manifs autorisée lorsque
des manifs qui sont autorisés par deux
notamment des grandes centrales
syndicales s'est entouré il ya un
service d'ordre espace passe bien on a
eu face à nous des casseurs ou autre
voilà pour nous le rapport il n'est pas
totalement adapté puis quand je dis
voilà c'est des gens qui me connaissent
du tout déjà le métier de policier et
qui veulent une fois de plus retiré le
peu d'armes d'un tamedia dont on dispose
on tenter de rétablir l'ordre public
on aurait plutôt préfère être sa part
des recommandations notamment lorsqu'on
des victimes nous policiers de cocktails
molotov de bouteilles d'acide ou autre
qu'est-ce qui préconise pour vous
protéger ou autre ça c'est n'ayant il ya
aucune mesure dessus voilà c'est plutôt
un rapport à charge une fois de plus
contre la police à un rapport à charge
du titre contre la police mais peut-être
aussi contre vis-à-vis des autorités qui
sont visés aussi par ce rapport il ya
toujours une connotation politique
alors ça on va les laisser entre
simplement et comme on dit nous parfois
il ya vraiment des choses à améliorer
notamment lorsqu'on utilise diffusé pour
déclarer notamment les charges ou autre
ou quand on parle de haut parleurs
pourquoi pas mais on peut pas non plus
retiré les intermédiaires 30 on dispose
on n'a rien pour lutter contre les
violences notamment quand j'entends le
port de cagoules notamment crs les
cagoules cd kaboul antifeu produite est
justement contre les cocktails molotov
je rappellerai que j'ai des collègues
qui ont été brûlé gravement encore assez
gpo de comment dirais-je projectiles on
a des collègues encore actuellement
contre des bouteilles d'acide
voilà donc c'est pour nous protéger ceux
reconnus et donnez donnez dans la
dotation de matériel par
l'administration
c'est vrai que ce rapport il intervient
dans un contexte quand même particulier
de dénonciation de violences policières
lors des manifestations par rapport à
ces dénonciations
quelle est votre position une position
déjà 12 usage de la force et au trail de
l'état pour nous au départ il n'y a pas
d'ingérence policière les collègues ont
dû faire face à des des attroupements il
faut le rappeler ces attroupements
c'était pas des manifestations qui est
autorisé chacun faisait ce qu'il voulait
dans son coin il s'amusait à café donc
je vais bien rétablir l'ordre
voilà donc ensuite si les gens estiment
avoir été victimes de violences
illégitimes
ils le font comme actuellement et c'est
gisti gipn ou par pas des médiateurs ou
autres et on verra
en tout cas c'est pas faire des manifs
mangera petz à des attroupements qui
n'était pas autorisée qui sont punis par
la loi c'est du délit notamment
lorsqu'on a scoré arbez alors dans ce
rapport aux 6,1 il ya des ja ce rapport
qui pointe aussi d'usagé abusif des
gardes à vue des interpellations groupe
et des contrôles délocaliser considéré
comme de la privation de liberté sur ce
point là précisément sur les sur les
contrôles j'ai lu qui mettant en avant
le fait de faire des contrats maman elle
est bien obligée notamment sur des
manifs s'abattrait leur efficacité parce
qu'on contrôle sans quitter bouger métro
ou les sacs et qu'on trouve des boules
de pétanque ou autre ce genre de
manifestation où on a on a fait ce genre
de contrôle et a permis d'avoir eu moins
de violences
alors ensuite la garde à vue c'est sûr
qu'ils aient prévu encadrait pas la loi
voilà les gens ici on ne retient rien
ils sortent à lasser des moyens qui sont
mis à disposition qui sont utilisés
alpes enfin pour moi ya pas trop trop
débat là dessus ce qui est visible c est
la violence que les collègues subissent
tu as par rapport à des attroupements
qui ne sont pas du tout autorisé alors
parmi les points précisément
que ce rapport dénonce il ya aussi
l'usagé abusif du lb d epuis la fin de
la technique de l'engagement qui
consiste à masser les manifestants sur
ces deux points là précisément qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
on revient toujours pas ce qui est dit
par certains groupuscules qui veulent
des armées la police
pour l'instant le npd est inutile à
match à l'ordre parce qu'ils touchent
notamment à maintenir à distance des
gens qui nous jettent par exemple à des
cailloux ou autre donc il est utile et
puis il ya les collections formé par
rapport à ça comme ça tu indiques c'est
le temps de formation
mais les collègues sont habilités à
utiliser et qui concerne aussi la nasse
s'est autorisé aussi dans les techniques
s'est renseigné à voir donc ça nous
permet de canaliser une foule et je le
répète quand il ya du matin lors des
affrontements les gens il faut pas non
plus qu'ils restent dans ce système là à
regarder
vous participez manière édifiante il
faut permettre aux forces de l'ordre
pour à l'isoler les casseurs afin de
pouvoir les neutraliser c'est ce qui est
important aussi il faudra du civisme
mais ça il emballe pas non plus merci à
vous il y aura un cavallero d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions sur rt
france rappelle que vous êtes délégué
national crs du syndicat alliance